ladies do you have a screenwriting
routine do we have a screenwriting
routine we have a bit of a screenwriting
righty we do um I guess what yeah uh I
come over to Janice's after work we she
cooks dinner we dinner we talk about
right now well right now we're in kind
of a rewrite phase so we're in a place
where r e conceptualizing some of the
relationships so we'll kind of have
those kinds of discussions over dinner
and then we'll go downstairs and we'll
look at the board and that's more of a
plotting kind of figuring out how these
new relationships are going to fit into
our new plot yeah so and it usually
always involves chocolate and some kinda
way that's our muse so yeah well Janice
I think you said previously that you
write at night like late at night and
barrington you're a morning person right
we do what we do both right um I think I
feel more inspired when the world is
quiet and the phones aren't ringing and
Twitter's not going off or the cell
phone isn't going off and I can kind of
let my imagination just run where it
wants to go because there's nothing
distracting and and I feel like even in
the work that I do is a journalist
that's when i get my inspiration I'm a
little bit more relaxed and I'm not I'm
actually not as self-conscious at night
as I am in the day something about the
lights being on and the light being up
makes me a little more like this has to
be this way and I think I can play in my
mind at night better now I have a
follow-up question to that because I I
know that Janice is somebody who will
say I'm going to go to bed i'm going to
set my alarm for like two or three a.m.
and i'm going to get up and i'm going to
work so when you say you work better at
night is it you stay awake all through
the day and then at night you find that
place or are you talking about when
you've gotten up
basically still in the middle of the
night yeah when I've gotten up in the
night so like I'll set my alarm for like
two or three o'clock and I'll get up and
usually like I'll have a shower so I'm
feeling kind of relaxed and comfortable
and I think when the shower starts well
I work well by water or with water I get
inspired because I'm not really thinking
about what I'm supposed to be writing
but the characters start coming alive to
me and and then because I do keep a pad
in my bathroom I need to write and and
then I go downstairs or go in my bedroom
or stay in my bedroom and just kind of
write things out and kind of free hand
things so yeah I think being in an
atmosphere where I don't feel like I
have to write right at a desk or a
computer I free write a lot by hand so
and then I take that and then put it on
the computer says oh yeah so that way
we're actually pretty similar because
it's almost like you're a morning writer
it's just that it's dark because because
I'm the same way I get up in the morning
and although I don't shower or do
anything I can't I of the Edith Wharton
School where I just kind of opened might
like stay in bed open my laptop and then
just start working because the minute I
go outside and see like the sink is full
of dishes I'm like maybe you'll do a few
dishes or something like that but if if
you just like kind of stay in squalor
ensconced in your bed you can get a fair
amount done before you have to really
face the world so that's that's good but
for me that's you know because I think
we we both tend to have a few projects
going on at once so usually it's not
this project that is the morning hours
project that's kind of more although it
will be again when we get into the
writing the out of the discussion phase
and into the right hang phase just out
of curiosity were either view born at in
the middle of the night or in the early
morning I know some
they say people do their best maybe that
theory doesn't work here i was born in
the afternoon okay all right there you
support it like 821 p.m. but I could eat
okay but that's very funny with writing
at night do you almost feel like there's
a pressure to be so perfect that in at
night time you can kind of let it go I
think that's really interesting yeah I
think for me because daytime is business
time that's when the journalism work
gets done that's when the emails get
taken care of that's when the phones are
on that's when I'm communicating with
people and since I live alone it's very
easy to for me to use the night as my
plate my personal playtime and so it's
the time when after dinner is over and I
live in a community and so nobody else
is awake you know even the world is
quiet you know there's nothing going I
live next to a park so nobody's playing
in the park there's nobody on the street
there are no cars it's just a very calm
serene peaceful time and so I get to you
know be like you know it sounds a little
wicked actually but its data it's like
it's like that's when I get to you know
I'm kind of a vampire in that way that I
get to you know do my thing and I really
get to connect with my either higher
power or muse or my other voice and and
really exercise at at nighttime so
that's that you know that that's when I
when I can feel you know even if I'm
listening to music that's when I can
hear the music and it in it you know
music became a big part of this of our
screenplay because I am so very
connected to music but I can hear music
in a different way than I at night then
I can during my daytime like something
about even a string instrument coming
out or or the lyric of
song a particular word in a song
resonates with me in a different way and
so through the writing process on those
times when I was alone and rewriting
without barrington I listened to music a
lot and I have certain soundtracks for
each character that really helped
inspire kind of the mood that I was
feeling or the the flow that I was
taking when I was prewriting alone
barrington for you is there something
about the structure of the morning and
knowing that I think you said you had to
be at work or out the door by noon or
something right yeah i work 12 to five
so right now so yeah it's like that uh
it's good so you know but with commutes
and stuff so I'm find out at 11 25 I'll
be right on time I'm usually out of 11
27 and then you missed the train and so
lateness has a whole different kind of
trajectory when you're dealing with some
some form of public transportation
because like two minutes late becomes
the next train which is ten minutes late
or 12 minutes late but anyway uh yeah
I'm somebody who I'm pretty happy when
I'm writing the mornings good you wake
up you do have less things going on in
the morning night time I I used to
really be able to get into a place at
night but I think it's mostly worrying
about getting up in the morning that
keeps me from writing late into the
night as much as I used to more and more
I think I'm getting into a place where I
you know with practice you get to a
place where you can just kind of dive in
from almost anywhere I mean I can pretty
much write on the train if i can get a
seat I can sure I can't write when I'm
driving so that's annoying but I can
kind of curl up anywhere and get a few
words I can't write and dry I know you
know it's funny because I dunno like
i'll have like a pad in the passenger
side and like I keep a pen
I keep pads and pens like hidden all
over the house and anywhere and there
are times when like something will hit
me and I'm just like okay sometimes I
can read it sometimes I can't but yeah I
too I do find that I I think it's
because I drive alone a lot you know I'm
alone a lot I'm a single person and so
and so I can choose when to engage with
others and so I think in my alone times
when you know even if there's like a
particular NPR story that had like we're
working on a story that has some contact
sub sub text to Los Angeles and housing
and so there was a story on and i was
like huh I need to write that down so
that i can tell barrington that we you
know we heard this you know story so
it's it's really interesting you know
just thinking about it now how connected
I am to a pen and a piece of paper at
all times but I don't write in cafes
well I tried that I it's too distracting
for me yeah it's not my favorite yeah
either I mostly those are those are like
token writing sessions where a friend is
asks you they're like oh you want to go
right at the you know blah blah you're
like oh I'd like to catch up with that
friend you don't actually think i have
it if you have a real deadline you're
like no yeah the only time i did do a
cafe writing was when I was really
trying to eavesdrop on certain kinds of
conversations and wanting to get a flow
in a rhythm for like a particular voice
that was the only time but it wasn't you
know it was there I was there snooping I
was eavesdropping I was you know I
wanted to hear something different than
I would hear in my own voice and so
that's when cafe writing or other kinds
of out but usually i'm in my my home
office or somewhere around my house
you